[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في حصاد الليله معكم
حسن جمول
وفي الوقت الذي يحدثكم فيه تقع واحداث
وتتفاعل اخرى
البدايه من غزه حيث نشرت كتائب القسام
هو ورفاقه لدى حركه حماس
وفي مدينه دافوس السويسريه الدوره 53 من
المنتدى الاقتصاديه العالميه تنطلق تحت
شعار التعاون في عالم مجازا وبمشاركه 2700
شخص
ومن بيروت نختم هذه الجوله بزياره وفد
قضائيا من ثلاثه بلدان اوروبيه للاستماع
لافادات مسؤولين اللبنانيين بصفتهم شهودا
في قضايا تتعلقوا بالاسراء غير المشروع
وتهريب الاموال
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
في اول رساله مصوره منذ اعلان اسره القسام
تعرض تسجيلا لجندي اسرائيلي اسير لديها
عائله الاسير تدعو لاسترداده بشكل فوري
نتنياهو يقول ان نشر المقطع المصور خدعه
ستؤخر فرصه الوصول لصفقه لتبادل الاسرى
ورئيس هيئه الاركان الاسرائيلي المنصرف
يقول ان ملف التبادل شهده تقدما قبل ان
يتوقف بسبب الانتخابات الاخيره
في حصيله هي الاعلى منذ بدء الحرب في صفوف
المدنيين اكثر من 40 قتيلا في هجوم على
مبنى سكني في دنبرو الجنوبيه اوكرانيا كيف
تقول ان القذف ناجم عن استهداف روسي متعمد
وموسكو تنفي مسؤوليتها وكاميرا الجزيره
ترصد في عين المكان تداعيات الهجوم
قبل ايام من اجتماع لحلفائك ياسر انشتاين
الكريم الكريم
المتزايده الى اوكرانيا ويتوعد باحراق
الدبابات الغربيه الممنوحه لكيات
ومساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه يقول
للجزيره انه واشنطن تتعاون مع شركائها
لتزويد اوكرانيا بما تحتاجه في ظل استهداف
بنيتها التحتيه الخاصه
في ظل وضع الجيو سياسيا واقتصاديا هو
الاكثر تعقيدا منذ عقود منتدى دافوس يبحث
قضايا اوكرانيا والركود الاقتصاديه
والتحديات المناخيه
وبالتزامن مع الافتتاح منظمه اوكستان تدعو
الى فرد ضرائب على الاثرياء وتقول ان
واحدا في المئه من سكان الارض
استحوذوا على ضعف ما يملكه باقي سكان
العالم خلال العامين الماضيين
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصه
الرقميه
ناقشنا نشره كتائب عز الدين القسام ذراع
المسلح لحركه حماس مقطع عن مصورا يظهر
الاسير الاسرائيليه لديها اثرها الذي
يتساءل في المقطع الى متى سيظل في الاسر
هو ورفاقه بعد هذه السنوات الطويله من
المعاناه والالم حسب تعبير وقال مكتب رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي ان نشر الفيديو
اي فرصه للوصول الى صفقه بشان الاسرى
والاستطلاع يا رايكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
قطر نحن عليكم السؤال التالي برايكم ما
دلاله اهداف ناشد القسام المقطع المصور
للجندي الاسرائيلي الاسير في هذا التوقيت
60 في المئه قالوا ان الهدف هو الضغط على
حكومه نتنياهو وقال 13% ان الهدف هو اظهار
ومسؤوليه اسرائيل في حين راى 27% ان كتائب
القسام نشرت الفيديو لتخفيف ضغط الاحتلال
على الضفه الغربيه هذا السؤال سيبقى
مطروحا على منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول
صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز
يتجدد يوميا وان نتطرى خلاله لقضايا
مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
وفي ثقله المتابعه في حصاد الليله نتوقف
عند حوادث الطيران في النيبال ومسائل
التضاريس
وظروف المناخ
[موسيقى]
نشرت كتائب القسام ذراع المسلح لحركه حماس
مقطع فيديو يظهر الاسير الاسرائيليه لديها
اثرها
قالت كتائب القسام من الفيديو دليل على
فشل رئيس الاركان الاسرائيلي المنتهيه
ولايته اذيبته
في تحرير الجنود الاسرى لدى حركه حماس
رساله في لحظه سياسيه مهمه توقيتا وسياقا
بالنسبه نداء الجندي الاسرائيلي المحتجز
لدى كتائب القسام جاء بالتزامن ما حدث
اسرائيلي مهم وهو تسلم هاليفي رئاسه
الاركان في جيش الاحتلال خلفا للرئيس
السابق كوخافي تاكيد على ما اعلنه القائد
يحيى السنوار قبل اسابيع من ان هناك نافذه
وقت محدوده للوصول الى صفقه تبادل والا
سيغلق هذا الملف نهائيا وتبحث المقاومه عن
ادوات لتحرير الاسرى جديده
هذه الرساله اتت ايضا بعد عده رسائل
وجهتها كتائب القسام خلال الفتره الماضيه
تهدف في مجملها الى تشكيل ضغط على اصحاب
القرار في دوله الاحتلال لدفعهم الى
التوصل الى صفقه لتبادل الاسرى على غرار
صفقه كالعاد شاليط
واظهار صور منجستوا بهذا الشكل ومع بدايه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده في عهد
الرئيس اركان جديده لا شك انها رساله
للحكومه الجديده بان ارسل الحكومه السابقه
الثقيل فيما يتعلق بملف الاثر لا يزال
الحاضرا ايضا هذه رساله للجمهور اسرائيل
لمنقسم اليوم ونحن نتحدثته الذي هو من
شريحه الاثيوبيين وغير خاف كذلك ما لتوقيف
هذه الرساله من صله بما يجري من توترات في
اوساط الاسرى الفلسطينيين داخل سجون
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في ظل حكومه نتنياه
جديده التي استقبلت بمظاهرات من قبل عشرات
الالاف من الاسرائيليين
وبعيدا عن دلالات هذه الرساله ومدى تحقق
مقاصدها فانها بلا شك تؤكد حقيقه واضحه
مفادها بان ملف الاسرار سيكون من الملفات
الساخنه خلال الفتره المقبله وائل الدحدوح
الجزيره غزه فلسطين
[موسيقى]
يفتحوا فيديو الجندي الاسرائيلي الاسير في
قطاع غزه البابا على ملف التبادل بين
المقاومه الفلسطينيه واسرائيل في التقرير
التالي نتعرف على الاوراق التي يملكها
كلاب طرفين في هذا الملف
المقاومه الفلسطينيه تواجه اسرائيل الفضل
تعلن حركه حماس ان بيدها اربعه جنود
اسرائيليين لا تفسح مصيرهم بينما تقول
اسرائيل انهم اما جثث او مدنيه من تعترف
اسرائيل بانهم جنود في جيشها شاؤول ارون
وهارجل
ارون بالجيش الاسرائيلي وعمل فيه لواء
النخبه على الحدود مع قطاع غزه شارك في
الحرب على القطاع عام 2014
حتى الان لم تقدم حركه حماس اي معلومات
خاصه به
الجندي هدار جولدن يحمل رتبه ملازم ثاني
بالواء دفعه في الجيش الاسرائيلي اصره
مقاتل القسام في منطقه رفح اثناء حرب 2014
ارتكبت اسرائيل مجزره في رفح ردا على اسري
جولدن قتلت فيها اكثر من 100 فلسطينيه
بينهم اطفال ونساء بعد انتهاء حرب 2014
باسابيع قليله اجتاز افرانجستو السياج
الفاصله بين اسرائيل وشمالي قطاع غزه
واختفت اثاره ولد من جست في اثيوبيا ثم
هاجرت عائلته الى اسرائيل وهو في عمر خمس
سنوات واقامت في مدينه عسقلان تقول عائلته
انه مضطرب النفسيه وتم تسريحه من الجيش
اتهمت عائلته الحكومه الاسرائيليه مرات
عديده بتعمد اهمال ابنها لاسباب العنصريه
لانه من اصول الاثيوبيه قالت كتائب القسام
بعد اعتقاله بخمس سنوات ان اسرائيل لم
تطالب باعاده من انجزته من خلال الوسطاء
الذين تحدثوا معها بشان المحتجزين
الاسير الرابع هو هشام السيد فلسطيني ومن
النقب يحمل الجنسيه الاسرائيليه تقول
المصادر الاسرائيليه انه دخل قطاع غزه
وبيع عام 2015 عبر ثغره في السياج الفاصل
بين اسرائيل وجمالي القطاع تقول مصادر
فلسطينيه انهد دراسته الثانويه وتطوع
للخدمه في الجيش الاسرائيلي عام 2008
وسرحت العام نفسه لانه غير مناسب للخدمه
ما ظهر حتى الان بشكل رسمي مقطع فيديو
نشره القسام اواخر يونيو الماضي للجندي
الاسرائيلي اسير هشام السيد على سرير
المرض وتظهر بطاقته العسكريه
اسرائيل قبل ذلك باسابيع قليله حصلت
الجزيره عبر برنامج ماخفي اعظم على تسجيل
صوتيا لاحد الجنود الاسرى دون الافصاح عن
هويته يكون فيديو منجستو هو الاول من حيث
ظهور الاسير بالصوت والصوره ما في يد
المقاومه ورقه مهمه بالنسبه الى
الفلسطينيين قائمه طويله من الاسرى احياء
وامواتا مئه محكومين بالمؤبدات منهم منذ
ما قبل اتفاق اوسلو عام 93 وعشرات نساء
والاطفال والمرضى اكثر من 370 جثه لشهيد
تتمسك اسرائيل بهذه الجثث لاستخدامها في
مفاوضات التبادل هؤلاء الاسرى احياء
وشهداء ليس مجرد ارقامها بالنسبه الى
ذويهم كذلك تقول المقاومه الفلسطينيه
المراسل العسكريين للقناه الثالثه عشره
الاسرائيليهلر كيف يمكن ان تتعامل حكومه
اسرائيل حكومه نتنياهو مع هذا التطور
الجديد مع هذا التسجيل
للاسير لدى حماس من جيستو
في الحقيقه
حماس الارهابيه وهي تستخدمه
وتحاول ان تؤثر سلبا على اليوم السعيد في
اسرائيل تغيير قياده الجيش الدفاع
الاسرائيلي وما رايناه اليوم هو ان حماس
يائس وتود ان همم
لتبادل الاسرى وهي تستخدم
في اسمه
ولديه مشاكل نفسيه ولضغط على الراي العام
الاسرائيلي لان المنظمه تعرف ان
الحكومه الاسرائيليه لنا تطلق صلاح
ارهابي من السجون الاسرائيليه من اجل
اطلاق السراح هذا الشخص الذي يعاني من
مشاكل نفسيه من جيسته والذي دخل الى
سنسال حماس ماذا تريد وماذا تهدف من من
هذا الامر عفوا سنسال حماس ما الذي تريده
هو ما هي رسائلها لكن سؤالي لك همم عما
ستقوم به اسرائيل تقول ان اسرائيل لن تقوم
بعمليه تبادل ولكن لطالما قامت اسرائيل
بعمليه تبادل مع اشخاص بين هلالين هي
تعتبرهم همم ارهابيين مقابل جنود وباعداد
كبيره جدا لماذا من جسته افرى من جسده همم
غير محظي همم كالعاده شليط مثلا
نيكوز جيلان شرير
كان جنديا اسرائيليه خطفه الارهابيون من
حماس من داخل الاراضي الاسرائيليه اما
امنجسترو هو شخص مدني يعاني من اضطرابات
النفسيه وهو
يستخدم
الاعقاقير او الادويه ودخل بيرادته الى
قطاع غزه طبعا كل انسان يعرف ان هذه
المشكله يجب ان تحل بالسبل او بالطرق
الانساني
وايضا هناك جنود اخرون لا تبالي بهم لا
حكومه اسرائيل ولا همم القياده الجديده في
اسرائيل
جنديه
عن الجنود الاخرين الذين تحدث عنهم من جست
ايضا
اسرائيل لن تطلق سراح الارهابيين الاحياء
الذين قتلوا
الاسرائيليين من اجل اطلاقي او الحصول على
جثث
الجنود الاسرائيليين من عمليه 2014
في السابق واكثر من مره وانت تعرف ذلك
تماما كان الموقف لاسرائيلي كما تقول ثم
خضعت اسرائيل وجرت عمليه تبادل لماذا الان
هذا الامر غير مقبول وهو الذي حصل سابقا
مع جنود اخرين
ديكوز بنجام
عشر سنوات وكما تتذكر اطلق سراح
ارهابي بما في ذلك
الارهابيه المسؤول السنوار المسؤول عن
حركه حماس في قطاع غزه اسرائيل لن
ترتكب بنفس الخطا مجددا لن تطلق سراح
الارهابيين وهذه السياسه التي اعتمدتها
اسرائيل منذ العام 2014 بعد العمليه التي
قامت بها ولذلك تستخدم حركه حماس هذه
لبروفندا من خلال استخدامه هذا الشخص
المدني الذي يعاني من اضطرابات عقليه
ونفسيه لكي نتحدث عن هذا الموضوع الان
وهلر المراسله العسكري للقناه الثالثه 10
الاسرائيليه كنت معنا من تل ابيب
وللحديث عن نفس الموضوع عن معنى من غزه
علي العمود القيادي في حركه حماس
اول رد فعل السيد علي العمودي لنتنياهو
اعتبر ان الامر خدعه تاخر الوصول الى صفقه
بشان الاسرى تماما هكذا قال
ما ردوا حماس على ذلك
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله
تحيه كل التحيه لابناء شعبنا المرابطين في
كل مكان والاسرانا الابطال في سجون
الاحتلال
اخي حسن نحن لسنا في معرض الردود على كلام
الاحتلال وعلى ما يدعيه
نتنياهو ومكتبه نحن في معركه مستمره هذه
المعركه متعدده الادوات والميادين والاوجه
هدفها الاساسي هو تحرير اسرانا واا
ما شهدناه اليوم هو في اطار هذه المعركه
التي تقودها كتائب القسام والمقاومه وحركه
حماس بكل حكمه ووقتدار العدو يفهم ويعلم
جيدا بان اطلاق سراح اسرانا هو امر محتوم
اتم لا محاله وكل الاعيبه ومحاولات
المواطنه لا تفيد ولا تفيده
وسنكون قريبا باذن الله على موعد مع صفقه
وفاء احرار ثانيه باذن الله سبحانه وتعالى
يتحرر فيها اسرانا الابطال من سجون
الاحتلال على اي همم اساس في في وقت لا
تبدي اسرائيل علنا همم
ايجابيه تجاه اتمام صفقه من هذا النوع على
اي اساس تتامل حماس حصول صفقه تبادل
حماس همم لا تتامل همم فقط استاذ حسن همم
حماس همم والمقاومه وكتاب القسام تعمل ليل
نهار في كل الميادين وبكل الادوات وبكل
الوسائل لتحرير اسرانا في سجون الاحتلال
ولها همم في ذلك همم تجربه طويله اكثر من
اثنا عشر من اثني عشر عمليه اثر لجنود
الاحتلال لديها اربعه اسرى همم من جنود
الاحتلال همم
معتقلين في قطاع غزه
وهمم هذه الادوات وهذه ال- همم
المعطيات اذا لم تكن همم كافيه لاطلاق
سراح الاسرى فانا همم ابشرك بان الجهد
مستمر وان همم ليس سرا بان قياده الحركه
وقياده كتائب القسام اعلنت بشكل واضح ان
انها يزيد الغله في هذا الاطار واذا العدو
لم يفهم ولم يكفه ما هو موجود فسيفهم همم
حينما يكون موجود اكثر ان شاء الله رب
العالمين بالحديث عن الجنود الاسرى كان
لافتا ما قاله افرى من جسته همم الى متى
همم ابقى انا ورفاقي في ظل المعاناه
والالم بحسب تعبيره هل همم هل هذا الكلام
معناه ان رفاقه انه من الاربع احياء
هو تحدث وهو يعرف
رفاق هو المكان الموجود فيه ومن هو موجود
في بالنسبه لي اييي ليس لدي معطيات او
معلومات في هذا في هذا الموضوع ولكن حينما
اتحدث عن نفسه عن رفاقه بالتاكيد هو يعرف
عن ماذا يتحدث
شكرا لك على العمودي القيادي في حركه حماس
حدثنا من غزه
وعد رئيس هيئه اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي
الجديد هرتسي هاليفين من وصفهم باعداء
اسرائيل وفي كلمه خلال مراسم تسلم منصب
رئيس الاركان خلفا لافيف كوخافي قالها
ليفي ان اسرائيل تحولت من دوله محطه
بالدول المعاديه الى دوله تطوق اعداءها
بقوتها وقدرتها المتطوره وفي شان الداخليه
انه سيوسع نطاق التجنيد ليشمل الجيش فئات
المجتمع الاسرائيلي كافه واعلن ان الجيش
سيستعد لشن الحروب سواء كانت بعيده نطاق
قريبا لكنه سيفعل ذلك بمعزل عن اي
اعتبارات غير امنيه حسب تعبير
بقينا الثالث لخوض حروب في ميادين بعيده
واخرى قريبه سنوسع تجنيد النوعيه للجيش من
كل فئات المجتمع وبكل قواتنا سنعمل على
تقويه جيش الاحتياط وسنحافظ على الجيش
موحدا واخلاقيا ومهنيا بعيدا عن اي اعتبار
غير اعتبار الامن
وعلى مستوى تصيد الاسرائيلي في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه استشهد الطفل الفلسطيني عمر
البالغ من العمر 14 عاما متاثرا باصابه
برصاصه في الراس اطلقها جنود الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في مخيم الدهيشه جنوب مدينه
بيت لحم الضفه الغربيه وكان المخيم قد شهد
مواجهات بين شبان فلسطينيين وقوه الاحتلال
خلال اقتحام قوه عسكريه اسرائيليه للمخيم
فاشلا اليوم
وفي جنوب جنين بالضفه الغربيه اصيب
فلسطينيون بجروح خطيره واعتقل ثلاثه خلال
اقتحام عشرات الاليات الاسرائيليه بلده
قباطيه وفد مراسل الجزيره ان مواجهه
اندلاع بين الفلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال
التي انتشرت اطلاق قنابل الغاز والاعياد
المطاطيه والذخيره الحيه
[موسيقى]
الى مدينه دينيبر الاوكرانيه حيث ارتفع
عدد القتلى القتل الهجوم على مجمع سكنيين
الى اربعين في معتبر عشرات في عداد
المفقودين هو الهجوم الاسود من حيث عدد
القتلى بين المدنيين منذ بدء حرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا قبل قرابه 11 شهرا الكريم في
مسؤوليته عن الحادث ويحمل المضادات
الاوكرانيه المسؤوليه المكياج فقالت ان ما
حدث في دينيبر ناجم عن استهداف روسي متعمد
كاميرا الجزيره في عين المكان ترصد
تداعيات الهجوم
لا تزالوا عمليات ازاله الركام مستمره في
مدينه دنيترو بعد الهجوم الذي تعرض له
مجمع سكني وخلف عشرات الضحايا والمصابين
وترك ايضا اثاره على وجوه الناجين
ووجدانهم اذ ما يزال البعض منهم يعاني
الصدمه من ما حدث
لم اسمع صوت الانفجار وكانه موجه انقذتني
استيقظته فوجدت نفسي مدرج الدماء
تسبب الهجوم في تدمير 230 شقه وفق السلطات
المحليه التي تسعى لازاله كل العثرات في
سبيل البحث عن ناجي
بعض البيوت المجاوره التي تعرضت لدمار
الجزئي يسعى اهلها
وامها الى ازالته بسرعه
باذى اشكر كل ما يقدم يد العون كنا
محذوفين على عكس اخرين اذ لم نفقد احد
تكشف الماساه عن وجه اخر قد يكون مشرقا
تتجلى فيه صور للتكافل
افراد ومنظمات يسعون لتخفيف اللعب عن
المتضررين عبر تقديم كل انواع المساعدات
سيكون لهذا الهجوم انعكاسات بلا شك كما
تقول جينا ولربما سيدفع البعض الى الرحيل
كممرضه وكمواطنه اوكرانيه ولان الوضع خطير
جدا
كانت هذه المحطه الاخيره في حياه من رحلوا
في هذا الهجوم وان كان الحزن قد ملا وجوه
احبائهم
لكنه هناك وجوها اخرى تظهر الامل على
استحياء
تركض اي خبر مفرح عن من بقي محاصرا وان
كانت ملامح المشهد لا تبشر بالكثير
عن سقوط الصاروخ فوق هذا المبنى السكني
وما تزال حقيقه ما حدث غامضه حتى الان لكن
حقيقه اخرى باتت واضحه فقد شرد كثيرون من
بيوتهم قتل اخرون ليتحولوا الى مجرد ارقام
في هذه الحرب التي يبدوها لن تطفئها بروده
الشتاء
عمر الحاج الجزيره
الامريكيه في المانيا
سنحرق الدبابات الغربيه
استراتيجيات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا بدات
تاخذ منحا مختلفا عن الاشهر الماضيه وتلك
لا تقتصر على التقدم والتراجع في ارض
المعركه بل تتعداها الى تحضيرات من
الجانبين
اوكرانيا تطلب مزيدا من الدعم الغربي وزير
خارجيتهادم يدرك التفوق الروسيه في
القدرات الصاروخيه فيطالب بقتل صناعه
الصواريخ والطائره بدون طيار بضربه عقوبه
جمعيه
يقول المتحدث
كاس كوفيره بذلك الى طلبك كيف تزويدها
بدبابه ليوبارد اثنين فيقول ان هذه
الدبابات ستحترق
روسيا تقرا استمرار تدفق السلاح على
اوكرانيا بانه تكتيك هجومي وليس دفاعيا
على الاقل في شبه جزيره القرم قاعده
الاصول الروسيه على البحر الاسود
للمكان اهميه عسكريه واستراتيجيه بالغه لا
تزال موسكو غير قادره على تحيده بالكامل
عن خط القتال يقول حاكم
ان انظمه الدفاع الجوي واسطول البحر
الاسود
اسقطت ثمانيه طائرات مسيره لدى اقترابها
من المدينه في هجوم استمر ساعات وليس
الاول من نوعها
يا ترافق ذلك مع وصول 100 جندي اوكرانيا
الى قاعده عسكريه امريكيه في اوكلاهما
للتدرب على استخدام منظومه باتريك وفي وقت
تتخوف كياف من تحضيرات الروسيه لضربه اوسع
انطلقت مناورات بين روسيا وبيلاروسيا
تدريبات تقراها كيف بانها خطوه لاعاده
التجميع القوات الروسيه او لنقل مزيد من
الحشود العسكريه الى الشرق مدنيه
انا بخمط فتبقى في دائره الضوء مع تقارير
بسيطره القوات الروسيه على مواقع جديده
للجيش الاوكراني جنوبي المدينه وتهاجم
الضواحي الشماليه وهما ينفيه الجيش
الاوكراني ويتحدث عن خسائر الروسيه
الفادحه في بخمه ومحيطها
المتحدث باسم القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه
سيد يوري الاسلحه والعتاد الغربي الذي
تزوج به اوكرانيا
من قبل الغرب حتى الان الى اي مدى يمكن ان
يغير مجرى المعارك
نظره ثانيه
المعدات التي تاتي لتسليح القوات الجويه
والقوات العسكريه بشكل عام تقوم بعمليات
ناجحه راينا ان العدو الروسي يحارب احيانا
بمعدات واسلحه
واستخدمت في الحرب العالميه الثانيه وهو
يقوم بتدمير كل شيء على طريقه في ماريو
اوبل في شرق اوكرانيا وفي مختلف المناطق
التي يقوم بقصفها كما قصفه سوريا بالضبط
والقوات الاوكرانيات تستمر
بالدفاع
وقد لا نتقدم كثيرا ولكن انا نقوم بمد
الجيش الاسلحه الغربيه الدقيقه والمتطوره
والفعاله والقادره على تدمير العدو دون ان
يؤذي المدنيين هو هذا اظهرناه واثبتناه في
القوات الجويه والمعدات التي قدمت للقوات
الجويه مثل همم
المضادات الجويه الالمانيه
والانظمه المدفعيه انها معدات تقوم بمئه
بالمئه بتدمير الهجمات الجويه مثل
المسيرات الايرانيه
ولذلك هذه الانظمه تقريبا تدمر كل
هجمات للاسف عدد هذه المعدات قليل نحتاج
المزيد من الشركاء حتى نعمل على الدفاع
ننتظر الانظمه
وانظمه اخرى اذا حصلنا على قرارات ايجابيه
من شركائنا لدي سوف يكون لدينا انظمه
لتدمير طائرات والصواريخ البلاستييه
والمروحيات همم ان الصواريخ البلاستيه
التي
تستخدمها همم روسيا
والاسلحه التي نحصل عليها وتقدم
للقوات البريه هي انظمه همم
الراجمات الصواريخ هاي مارد وغيرها
الفعاله وهايبرس
صواريخ عاليه الدقه نستخدمها ضد العدو
بفعاليه
رغم ذلك يعني واضح ما ما تقوله لكن رغم
ذلك هناك تقدم روسي على الارض واخرها مثلا
السيطره كما همم اعلنت روسيا على مدينه
سوليدار وهو امر استراتيجي ومهم بالنسبه
اليها في التقدم
نور
مصر اليوم
المعارك الساخنه
وهذه المعارك مستمره لاكثر من شهر لذلك
هذه منطقه سكانيه صغيره كما تعلمون
فيها الكثير من
ممرات تحت ارضيه
هو في ذلك المكان تقدم الروس
لمسافات قصيره جدا ولم يجتاحوا اماكن
كبيره ولكن اريد ان اذاكر انا بخ متواصل
للدار هناك معارك مستمره تقوم بها القوات
الاوكرانيه بالمستحيل لقد دمرنا الالاف من
القوات الروسيه مثل فاجنر ومثل
المرتزقه المتواجدين هناك قد يكون تقدموا
في بعض الجبهات ولكنها قليله جدا ولكن
العدو يخسر الكثير على ارض المعركه
ويمد هناك اغلب قواته ولا استطيع ان اسمي
هذا نجاح من قبل القوات الروسيه لان الثمن
الذي يدفعونه لاجل منطقه صغيره يحاول
اجتياحها او يسيطر عليها هذا فقط ليثبت
للاداره انهم قاموا بنجاح او بناصر رمزي
انهم يسيرون على جثث جن بهم
ويمد المنطقه بالجنود حتى يقتل باكبر عدد
يخرجون المساجين من السجون حتى يحاربوا مع
صفوف الفاكنر لذلك هم يخسرون خساره محسوسه
كبيره
العسكري والعقيد الاحتياط في الجيش الروسي
سيد الدكتور مرحبا لماذا تبدي روسيا كل
هذه الخشيه من الدعم العسكري نوعيه الدعم
العسكري الذي بدا يصل الى اوكرانيا او
تتدرب عليه القوات الاوكرانيه
علما انه من النوع الدفاعي وليس من النوع
الهجوم
فواتير نحن لا نخشى ولا نشعر باي خوف قبل
هذه المعدات دعوهم يدربوا من يريدون اولا
هذه الدبابات ليست الدفاعيه التي تريد ان
تقدمها بريطانيا او التي تريد ان تقدمها
البولنديون نحن لا نخشى هذه المعدات دمرنا
الكثير من المعدات التي وصلت لاوكرانيا من
قبل الولايات المتحده ودول الناتو نحن
سندمر المعدات الجديده التي ستصل الى هناك
مع الذين يعملون عليها
لذلك ليس لدينا اي مشكله في هذا الحرب
وهنا قتله وضحايا
طيب الان
نعم هناك هناك منورات هناك منورات في
الجزء الشمالي في المنطقه الشماليه بين
روسيا وبين القوات الروسيه والبيلا روسيه
شمال اوكرانيا ما هدف هذه المناورات خصوصا
انها مناورات جويه
سنويا
والمشاه
المحاربين الذين همم يتدربون على انظمه
الدفاع الجويه ليس هناك اي شيء ليس هناك
اي شيء جديد في ما يحدث في ذلك ليس من
ضروري
تكبير ما يحدث
وكانه شيء جديد انه
اننا نتعلم على ان ندافع على انفسنا ضد
اوكرانيا وضد بولندا حيث
يقوموا بوضع جنود وجلب الجنود الامريكيه
هل تتوقع هل تتوقع بعد
مرور ايام الشتاء ال همم
القاسيه ان تكون هناك هجمات وهجمات همم
مضادقه تكون حاسمه تحديدا في الجزء
الشرقيه من اوكرانيا
ان هذا لن يحدث بعد الشتاء هذا سيحدث
اثناء الشتاء وهذه الهجمات على الشمال سوف
تكون هجمات روسيه بعد ان حررنا سندار
وقريبا سوف ناخذ سوف ناخذ ارتوماس اي ضخمت
وعندها سوف نطهر مناطق تماما
ترك ايضا سوف يحرر
في الجيش الروسي من موسكو شكرا جزيلا لك
في مقابله خاصه مع الجزيره قال مساعد وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه لشؤون الطاقه جيفري
بياته ان استخدام روسيا للطاقه كسلاح
افقدها مصداقيتها كمورد عالميا للطاقه
كمورد عالمي للطاقه
كسلاح افقدها مصداقيتها كمورد للطاقه
يمكننا ان نرى ذلك في اوروبا على وجه
الخصوص والتي كانت مرتبطه مع روسيا في هذا
المجال لسنوات لكن الحاله تغير اوروبا
توقفت الان عن استقبال الغاز الروسيه عبر
الانابيب وهو ما احدث صدمه في الاسواق
العالميه
واضاف بيئه في مقابلته مع الجزيره ان
الولايات المتحده تعمل مع شركائها على
مساعدتك في تجاوز الازمه الناجمه عن ذلك
الشهر الماضي ورايتم قامت به روسيا من
استخدام فصل الشتاء كثيرا واستخدام
الهجمات على منشات الطاقه لاجبار
الاوكرانيين على تقديم تنازلات نحن نعمل
جاهلين مع كل شركائنا الدوليين كليابان
ومجموعه السبع حول العالم لمساعده
الاوكرانيين على الحصول على الادوات التي
يريدونها لتجاوز الازمه الانسانيه التي
تحاول روسيا افتعالها بحجماتها على منشات
الطاقه التحتيه تفوز دائما اجوايستيشن
[موسيقى]
في ذا فويس بدا منتدى سنوي تلتقي فيه نخب
سياسيه واقتصاديه عالميه
طامحه الى تعاون في عالم مشرد ما بين
الحرب في اوكرانيا والاختلال المناخي
والعولمه يقول رئيس المنتدى ان التجمعين
عقيد في ظل وضع جيو سياسيا ويجي اقتصاديا
هو الاكثر تعقيدا منذ عقوده وبالتزامن
كشفت تقرير صادر عن منظمه اوكستان ان اغنى
اغنياء العالم وتبلغ نسبتهم واحده في
المئه من سكان الارض استحوذ على ضعف ما
يملكها باقي سكان العالم خلال العامين
الماضيين
بالاقتصاد عرفناه لا بالسياحه
في جبال الالب سويسريه يحتضن منتدى الشهير
هذا العام
بارزون عن نسخه المنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي
الثالثه والخمسين
وبعضها الاخر من ارتدالات الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا ارتفاع اسعار المواد
الغذائيه ونقص امدادات الطاقه بينما
الاقتصاد العالمي المبتلى بالتضخم بدا على
حافه الركود
سيبحث الصناع القرار والنخب السياسيه
والاقتصاديه
هموم عالمنا الاقتصاديه المتشعبه تلك
وسيقررون بشانها
هكذا ابوهم في عالم لا تبدا الفوالق فيه
تزداد بين الفقراء واصحاب الثروه
يحاول منتدى دعوس بحسب شعاره ايجاد صيغه
للتعاون في عالم منقسم فكيف تراه يعالج
الخلل الذي يثيره تقرير صادم اصدرته منظمه
اوكسام غير الحكوميه بموازاه افتتاح منتدى
دابوس في التقرير المعنون البقاء للاغنى
نقرا ان اثر اثرياء العالم ونسبتهم واحد
في المئه من سكان المعموره حصلوا على
قرابه الضعف فيما يمتلكه باقي السكان خلال
العامين الماضيين
تقرير اقصى ما السنوي دعى الى فرض ضريبه
تصل الى خمسه في المئه على اصحاب الملايين
والمليارات بما يمهد لخفض عادتهم الى
النصف بحلول عام 2030 والغاء الثروات
متراكمه
الى ان الضريبه قد تدر سنويا ما يكفي
لانتشال مليار شخصين فقط
[موسيقى]
الفقر الاخرى اخرجت هؤلاء
تعيش المدينه على وقع تظاهرات ناشطيه
البيئه التي سبقت المنتدى الاقتصادي وقد
تلازمه
يقول نيكولا سيرجيست الذي يراس حزب الشباب
الاشتراكيه السويسري انه الامر المخزن اي
يناقش الاغنياء واصحاب النفوذ مستقبله
كوكبنا وراء ابواب موصدع لا يحتاج نيكولا
ورفاقه على ما سماه تقاعس الحكومات عن
اتخاذ الخطوات اللازمه لمكافحه التغير
المناخي فحسب وانما جاءوا ليطالب هم ايضا
بفرض ضرائب على الاثرياء والشركه الكبرى
فذاك ما سيخرج العالم في رايهم من ازماتهم
المتداخله
من نيويورك معنى ريتشارد الاقتصاد بجامعه
مرحبا بك
[موسيقى]
يعني سابدا من شعار منتدى دافوا السيد
ريتشارد ايجاد صيغه
صيغه تعاون في عالم منقسم ما مدى واقعيه
هذا الهدف لمنتدى الدافوس
ماتش في الحقيقه انا لا اتوقع الكثير
العالم كان
منقصما
قبل ان يكون العالم منقصما قبل ان تتعدد
الاقطاب
المسار او الاتجاه
العالميه للراسماليه لم يتغير الكلمات
الجميله حول انعدام
العداله وتكافؤ الفرص
والاثرياء تزداد ثروتهم وباقي الناس
يعانون هذه الطريقه لن نتعامل معها بطريقه
مناسبه الا الى ما اعترفنا باننا نعيش في
ظل نظام راس مالي هو لمصلحته الشركات
الكبرى هذا اولا وكل شيء اخر ثانوي وهذا
يزيد من انعدام العداله والتكافؤ وهذا
يؤدي الى زعزعه الاستقرار الاجتماعيه في
كل اقطار العالم وسوف ندفع جميعا غرامات
كبيره اذا ما لا يتم معالجه هذه المشكله
في القريب العاجل طيب كيف يتم الطلب من
الاقوياء من الاثرياء الذين هم من يحددون
السياسات التي تناسبهم بطبيعه الحال كيف
يمكن الطلب منهم ان يصلحوا هذا الواقع
الذين هم سبب وجوده
نحن كنا نطالب ونطالب وهم يستمتعون
بالاستماع الى مطالبنا في بعض الاحيان هم
يدلون بخطابات يقرون فيها بالمشكله ولديهم
بواعب قلق ايذائها وسوف يتصرفون ولكن
الحقيقه هي ان ما من شيء حصل لتغيير
الواقع وهم لا يزلون في موقع القوه سوف
اعطيكم مثالا بسيطا الملوك والملكات في
الماضي كانوا يقولون لنا سوف نحسن الاوضاع
سوف نعمل على الامور والصعوبات التي
تعانون منها لتحسينها ولكن النتيجه لم
تتغير الا حين قال الناس لا نود الملوك
لقد غيرنا النظام لكي نشارك جميعا على
الاقل من خلال التصويت للقاده يتعينوا
علينا الان ان نقوم بتغيير مماثل لكيفيه
تنظيم الشركات والاعمال فقط عندما نقوم
بذلك يخدم الاقتصاد الناس عوضا عن خدمه
الشركات الكبرى التي تسيطر على هذا العالم
فقط عند ذلك سوف تتغير النتيجه والا اذا
بقي الامر على حاله والاجتماع بين النسخ
في دافوس الى اخره كل هذه الامور لن تغير
النتائج التي اشارت اليها او اكثر
من نيويورك استاذ الاقتصاد بجامعه
شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الان الى حادثه تحطم طائره في
النيبال قبل وقت قصير من هبوطها وتبدد
الامال في العثور على ناجين رغم استمرار
جهود فرق الاغاثه فما الذي حدث
الطائره الصغيره كانت في طريقها من بلده
بكاره الواقع على بوادي نحو 200 كيلو متر
شمال غربيه
كيلومترا الى شمال الغربيه كانت الطائره
وهي من طراز اي تي ار 72 5200 تابعه لشركه
يدي في رحله تستغرق 20 دقيقه قبل ان تفقد
الاتصال ببرج المراقبه وتسقط في واد عمقه
ثلاث مئه
لا يزال له سبب الحادث مجهولا الا ان مقطع
مصورا يظهر طائره المجهزه بمحركين تجنحه
فجاه يسارا عند الاقتراب من مطار بكاره مع
سماعه يدويا في جار قوي توجد في النيبال
ثمانيه من اعلى 14 جدلا في العالم منها
جبل ادرس اعلى قمه في العالم الطقس يتغير
بسرعه الجبال وهو ما يخلق ظروف طيران
شديده التعقيده تضم النيبال بعضا اصعب
المدارج اذ تحيط بها قمم يشكل الاقتراب
منها تحديا حتى بالنسبه لاكثر التيارين
خبره وعاده ما تكون مهابط الطائرات فيها
في مواقع جبليه يصعد الوصول اليها
الماسات التي وقعت صباح الاحد واوده بحياه
العشرات هي اسوا كارثه جويه في نبال منذ
ثلاثه عقود ماذا عن تاريخي حوادث الطيران
في هذا البلد عرفت نبال عرفت اسوا الكوارث
الجويه في تاريخها في ايلول سبتمبر عام
1992 عندما قدم
167 شخصا كانوا علامتني طائره ايرباص اي 3
للخطوط الجويه الباكستانيه تحطمت لدى
اقترابها من كتمه وقبل شهرين من تلك
الحادثه في يوليو عام
1992 تحطمت طائره تابعه للخطوط تايلانديه
قرب المطار ذاته منا اسرى عن مقتل مئه
وثلاثه عشر شخصا
وتحطم الطائره تابعه للخطوط الجويه
الامريكيه البنغاليه اثناء رحله من دكا
الى كتماندو لدى هبوطها اوائل عام 2018 ما
اسفر عن مقتل 51 شخصا من بين 71 كانوا على
متنها في ايار مايو الماضي ادى تحطم طائره
توين اوتر تابعه لشركه تاره ايطاليا الى
مقتل 22 شخصا بعيده اقلاعيها من بكاره
وعثر على الحطام بعد يوم عند حافه جبل على
ارتفاع 4000 و 400 متر نشير هنا الى ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي يمنع خطوط الطيران
النيباليه من استخدام المجال الجويه منذ
عام 2013 عزاء ذلك لاسباب تتعلق بالسلامه
ينضم الينا من لندن تيري توزر الطيار
السابق والخبير في السلامه الجويه
يعني
المسؤول الاول كما يقال ويشع عن حوادث
الطيران هو ظروف المناخ هل هذا صحيح
ان الطقس كان جيدا وكان السماء صافيه لم
يكن هناك رياح قويه المطار في هذه الحاله
بالتحديد هو مطار دولي كبير فيه مدرج
للاقلاع والهبوط كبير وبالتالي لا اعتقد
ان الظروف كانت تشكل صعوبات بالمقارنه مع
الاماكن الاخرى التي تحط فيها الطائره
يعني
برايك هنا يعني باختصار شديد برايك ما هو
سبب المرجح طبعا الامر يحتاج الى تحقيق
ولكن بنظره عامه نتيجه خبرتك ماذا تقول
يبدو ان الطائره كانت تقترب بالضبط انا
واعلى ارتفاع من المقدمه وبعد ذلك
يشير الى انها كانت بسرعه بطيئه في الهواء
هناك
اجراءات وتدابير على الطائره اتخذ اجمالا
يمكن ان تتعدد العوامل على سبيل المثال
التيار يعاني من ازمه معينه او خطا
ميكانيكي معين ولكن بداوا بالتحديد ان
الطائره تطير ببطء شديد وبعد ذلك فقد
السيطره ههه طيب حوادث الطيران بشكل عام
ما هو سبب ال- ال-
الاكثر شيوعا لها
عايز
اكتب في كتابه نحن نتحدث عن نقطه مهمه في
السلامه الملاحه الجويه وهي ثقافه
الموجوده في شركات الطيران في حال لم يتم
اتباع الاجراءات تظهر المشاكل في احترام
الاجراءات واجراءات والتدابير السلامه
الامور يجب ان تسير على خير ما يرام البشر
نحن البشر نرتكب الاخطاء لذلك من الاهميه
في مكان ان نحاول ان نقلص من امكانيه
الخطا البشريه باكبر قدر ممكن ومن بين
الاسباب التي ادت الى منع الاتحاد
الاوروبي للخطوط الجويه النقليه من
الطيران فوق الاجواء الاوروبيه هو النقص
في التدريب
على هذا الطاقه
ولكن المعايير جزيلا شكرا لك
الطياره السابق والخبير في السلامه الجويه
من لندن
[موسيقى]
بالثلوج بعيدا عن عيون الفقراء يجتمع قاده
العالم واثريائه في ذا فويس
من سكان العالم يستحوذون على ثلثي ثرواته
هذا في دافوس اما في شمال غربيه سوريا
ارتفع الى 20 عدد وفيات مرض الكوليرا مع
تحذير من ارتفاع نسق الوفيات جراء مشكلات
في الصرف الصحي وتلوث المياه الشرب في 47
مخيما للنازحين هذه المخيمات نفسها كانت
ما زالت ارضيه خصبه لصنوف شتم من المعاناه
ولسان حال الصبيه السوريين فيها يقول من
لم يمت بالجوع مات بغيره تعددت الاسباب
والموت واحد دمتم في خير وعافيه الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]